the easiest way to get a job at
acquisition.com or really any great
company do the work that you're actually
good at ahead of time on behalf of what
you would start doing in the role if
you're good at web design you could like
redesign some pages and send it in if
you're really good at creative stuff
like you could take raw content edit it
and then send it in so the whole risk is
like what if they come in and they suck
well they're going to see your work
ahead of time and if you do that to a
hundred jobs then you also get practice
the whole way through of actually just
doing more reps so you're really working
on you more than you're working for them
if you think about applying for jobs or
getting jobs as cold outbound which is
exactly what it is cold outbound
benchmarks are about one percent as in
if you reach out to 100 people you get
one sale and so I think that most people
need to start thinking about jobs that
same way which is if you apply to 100
companies you're likely to get a job
especially if you actually take time and
don't just click apply send resume apply
send resume and never do any
personalization so just don't be lazy